i think both of you did what you set out
to do with this
what you wanted to do you did perfectly
what you wanted to do with this
you did it i'm getting nervous i'm
sweating it's over here
it's just an honor to see you eating my
face i'm trying not to freak out
[Music]
hey it's nicole russell from last dragon
pizza and welcome to peace awards on
first week feast
today is the battle of new york i'm
talking about round pie versus sicilian
queens versus brooklyn me versus frank
pinello
what's up i'm frank pinello i'm the
owner and operator of best pizza in
williamsburg brooklyn
typically when people talk about new
york pizza everybody's talking about the
fold the round slice
the neapolitan slice if you will to me
the sicilian slice the square
is just as iconic the reheat is
delicious
and the process is a little bit more
unique than making your regular round
pizza
well where i grew up the round pie was
really the main pizza that you got you
hardly ever got a sicilian
to me that round slice just hits a
little different
it's crispy thin oozy and delicious
so i'm a round slice girl all the way
today michael imperioli is the judge
he's an icon
for so many reasons but he grew up
in a similar way that i did you know i
feel like if i could pull on some of
those nostalgic chords
i might be able to win this heart
frank thank you so much for joining us
today i'm so happy to have you and the
goat goes first so what are you doing oh
wow
well first of all thank you for having
me i'm super excited to be here making
some pizza
today i'm doing the classic sicilian
pizza it kind of fits my heritage is
sicilian both of my parents from sicily
um we grew up eating a lot of that
svencione pizza
it's like a little bit thicker but today
i'm doing that classic
brooklyn style pizzeria shop square
we're going to jump right into it
basically pat out my dough get it into a
oiled pan
wrap it up let it proof and take it from
there
tell us and make the distinction between
sicilian pizza
grandma pizza all the pan pieces can be
like confusing
it's crazy because things are getting
super regional now so you have detroit
doing detroit style pizzas that are
square
and you know the grandma pizza which is
a little thinner
but the sicilian was a lot thicker if it
was made right it had a lot of air
inside of it and then when it got to
reheat it would kind of get nice and
crispy around the edges
so you would get the corner pieces right
and then usually one middle piece
and that was kind of a thing i was
always a corner your corner you see
you're pointing the girl i'm watching
not the quarter girl but you know what i
mean
i feel you i feel we're talking pizza
we're talking pizza
[Music]
all right so we're getting into the
sauce now right we want to pack a punch
i got a special little secret i got this
from my grandmother
where you use a razor blade right only
brooklyn people got a razor blade
i got you know keep it in the wallet
tucked away in case i need it
but the real secret to this whole recipe
is you gotta slice the garlic thin
so thin you put it in with the anchovies
that it liquefies in the pan okay
let's go and smell the aroma i can't
wait oh no no thank you for that
thank you nona this is just gonna cook
for a couple minutes you want to keep
your eye on it start to simmer
we're also just gonna take right out of
the can oh a little bit of tomatoes
the other thing i like to throw in there
is a little bit of thyme
while this is going nice and slow on a
simmer i'm just going to take my
tomatoes and throw them right in here
we're going to throw in some basil
rooster that's gonna be super flavorful
we have some of that beautiful oregano
all right
so we have our tomato sauce cooking now
we're gonna incorporate the base and
then we're gonna
dump this right into olive oil and all
and now we're going to get to the
finesse part of the actual sicilian so
you're dripping in finesse so let's go
i couldn't resist i couldn't resist
[Applause]
like a little drizzle of sauce just a
drizzle and now
this is where the finesse part comes for
this you really just want to use your
hand so you can
feel yeah feel it you know and i think
we did a really good job
we're gonna pop it in the oven and we're
gonna get our first shelf
all right so the sicilian shell just
came out of the oven it rose up nicely
so at this point we can get ready to put
our cheese on put our sauce on and pop
it right back in
can't wait let's go first things first
we got the mozzarella
that's it right now i have the cheese on
the bottom and i'm putting the sauce on
top
i'm kind of doing it in stripes as it
cooks it's going to spread
but this is very reminiscent i'm almost
like an l b pizzeria
beautiful throwing it in the oven 550
degrees then we'll be ready to eat can't
wait
we're gonna go right in right on top of
these stones that looks
beautiful
oh my goodness all right so the pizza
looks great
but underneath is still a little bit
soft what i'm going to do is transfer to
the cutting board
we'll cut it just like we do at the
pizzeria right but then when it's time
to serve
we'll pop it on the stone you know and
really get that crispiness that we want
[Music]
oh yeah so right now he's checking the
booty the boys look
good yup the underneath that's called
the booty
that's the booty shot you always gotta
check the booty that's
mine the corners
you're jealous you're jealous
you're jealous classic sicilian nice
puffy dough
it's got the look that we want corner
slice middle slice
manja manja manja manga let's see
oh it's the hot but all the sauce mmm
oh my god come on give a girl a chance
he's going so hard on me man what do you
think
trust i mean
it's so good it's a good shot the burnt
cheese
i like the freshness of the tomato on
there
it's so soft and you putting it back in
there on the stone made all the
difference i can tell
it's so nice and crispy this is your way
of disarming me
i know how it's going pizza was she's in
the camo
she's talking sweet she got that pretty
smile right
she's just homing me right now no it's
really good i know you're about to come
hard i'm gonna try my best you guys
ready to see what i do
i can't wait
frank your sicilian was delicious but
when i think of new york pizza i think
of the round pie and that's what i'm
gonna make for you today
[Music]
i have this nice and fluffy dough so
yeah you think so
yes i like to get what's called a nice
conecone yeah the crust that goes around
yes so the air is here and what i'm
gonna do is i'm just gonna
push out wow right into the crust boom
you see that i'm not gonna lie
that dough ball is what i look for in
pizza dough that type of air inside of
there
that to me is like the symbol of
a good tasting pizza so now i'm gonna
pick it up and i'm gonna just start
stretching it out
you know who taught me to stretch it
like this mark iacono taught me this
mark's a smart guy he was like nicole
use the gravity of the dough
and use the table and just stretch it
out to where you want it
right so now i'm gonna add some sauce
gotcha i already have my sauce because i
don't cook my sauce but i like my sauce
to marinate over days
just so the flavors can just get more
infused
you know i can be a little heavy-handed
with sauce because like i said i like a
juicy pizza yes
but don't do like me do like you i love
it and then i use grande cheese you know
grandes are number one cheese in the
pizza industry
why that whole milk you know yeah you
need that whole milk but you also don't
need as much
right spreads really nice how expensive
yeah but it spreads really nice
definitely how expensive
but it spreads i have to say that again
but
you know being a home cook and you're
paying for all these high quality
ingredients at home it's no joke
no joke but it's worth it yup so we're
gonna do 500 convection on this oven
here
beautiful five minutes then what i'm
gonna do is after five minutes i'm gonna
change the setting to broil
and i'm gonna finish off the pie damn
you know what i mean
that's how you get the crust what you've
done out of your home
kitchen it's mind-blowing to me because
you gotta figure it out all right i
think it's ready
i'm going to pull this baby out oh my
god so here we go
that's a piece of yeah that's the crust
almost like a great loaf of bread right
on okay frank i'm ready for you to try
it
let's go please let me know hot right
out the oven
oh my god i'm gonna try and slice it
with you this crops
cheers look at that
[Music]
yeah that's what i want you see when you
eat that
but you also got to get the stamps
don't mess with your dirt don't make up
your sneakers
stay crispy like this crush
[Music]
nicole i could barely talk because i'm
trying to enjoy this pizza but it is
delicious
um bewildered how you pulled it off you
nailed it
thank you so much i'm glad you liked it
that means the world to me
we had two amazing pieces today but this
isn't over we need a judge and michael
imperioli is here
can you believe that uh oh sopranos yeah
good fellas oh god piece of work oh god
we're here with michael imperioli the
legendary actor and he has a podcast
called talking sopranos thank you so
much for joining us my pleasure thank
you for having me what would you say
makes a great new york slice of pizza
the misconception is that if you get a
lot
it's good what's important is you know
everything in proportion
the subtlety things done fresh there's
not a lot of places to hide with pizza
so
every component has to really be on
point to be good
obviously the sopranos good fellas
i feel like food was a huge component to
those shows you know
italian american is there any specific
scenes of eating pizza or
rolling up to a pizzeria that stand out
to you there's a
famous scene where my character says
don't disrespect the pizza parlor
watch the [ __ ] you going kiss my ass
take that [ __ ] outside don't disrespect
the pizza parlor
you know you you have to honor your
neighborhood
it's a good place you know very often
you grow up on and then you take your
kids
to that place so it's it's serious
business it's a very
cultural big cultural thing
we were asked to prepare two new york
style pizzas i chose the square or the
sicilian
cheese on the bottom and the sauce on
top kind of like that l b style
really the secret was i sliced it garlic
really thin
with like a razor blade and then i put
it inside the pan so it liquefied in the
pan
all right can we try it yeah we at that
point know
please i hope you enjoy that's really
nice
all right here we go
i'm getting nervous i'm sweating it
looks really good
it's delicious really really good so you
got
the crispiness on the bottom a little
bit chewiness but the
middle of the dough is still supple
kind of burnt in little parts which i
love that other texture that other
you know really homemade flavor yeah
this is delicious
i'm glad you like it thank you i'm gonna
eat half it and save it so i don't
overwhelm my palette but i'm gonna get
back to that one
all right michael we have a classic
plain pie that we call at last dragon
piece of the glow
i grew up in queens and what i used to
like and i think i'm chasing nostalgia
in that way
i used to like a lot of garlic you know
of course the fundamentals are from new
york pizza but i just put my own little
twist on what i like
i just hope that you like it as well so
this doesn't feel like a
classic new york slice it has you know
it has weight but it's not heavy it's
like
it's you know because you're eating
stuff on the street so you need some
sturdiness so it's not going to be all
over the place looks really good so
okay
wow really it's
really really good thank you the crust
has a crispiness and it's also soft
if i went into a pizzeria in new york
and got this i'd be really really happy
it's just an honor to see you eating my
piece i'm trying not to freak out
it's really good
[Music]
[Applause]
all right michael now's the moment of
truth you tasted my pie you tasted
frank's pie
which one do you pick what's the winner
i'm gonna be really honest it's
really hard because i think both of you
you know did what you set out to do with
this what you wanted to do
you did perfectly what you wanted to do
with this you did it
if i have to choose one and it's really
very difficult
[Music]
i probably would go with frank's because
it reminds me of my grandmother's piece
it's okay so there's a sentimental
edge which is a little bit unfair frank
i heard
grandma and i was like no no
it's the only answer but like i said
if i went down the street and bought
this i'd be so happy and i think you
i think you're nailing this really
really good
[Music]
well frank you want it fair and square
and honestly
it's been an honor to have you you're a
legend
you're my inspiration and i just want to
tell you congratulations
thank you very much and to be honest i
wanted to tell you that
you know i got 10 years in the game you
know you've been cooking out of your
house and you started this new wave
but you actually have been inspiring me
you know
it makes me kind of get re-inspired
about pizza and want to get back to what
i love
for the first episode this is really
special michael thanks again
frank i love you thanks again tune in
next week on peace awards
you